right now WBAI concludes the other day
of broadcasting WBAI is owned and
operated by the Pacifica foundation a
non-profit educational institution which
got together to operate non commercial
radio stations in New York San Francisco
and the Los Angeles areas the Los
Angeles area the areas around Los
Angeles WBAI operates on channel 2 5 8
at 99.5 megacycles with an effective
radiated power of five point four
kilowatts horizontal and three point
eight five kilowatts vertical by
authority of the Federal Communications
Commission our transmitter is located in
the Empire State Building and our
studios and offices are at 30 East 39th
Street and 489 Fifth Avenue in New York
City thank you for joining us today and
we hope that a broadcasting has
encouraged you to join us again later
this morning at 7 o'clock Larry
Josephson will probably be here within
the beginning and radio unnameable
should be here at about midnight
tomorrow morning till then bye bye
[Music]
you